Now that we understand how HTML works,
we want to separate out these tags from the words that will be displaced on the screen.
Breaking up words like this is actually a surprisingly common task in real life.
For example, ancient Latin was often written or inscribed without spaces.
This particular set of letters "SENTATUSPOPULUSQUEROMANUS"
is inscribed on the arch of Titus, which I've doodled over here as a column,
but what can you do? Arches are apparently beyond my power.
I know. It has just become an arch. Those labels never lie.
Roman inscriptions like this were written without spaces,
and it requires a bit of domain knowledge to know how to break this up.
"Senate and the People of Rome." That inscription was made quite some time ago.
Similarly, in many written Asian languages, they don't explicitly include spaces
or punctuations between the various characters or glyphs.
In this particular Japanese example, and both my handwriting and my stroke order
are very, very poor--have pity--some amount of domain knowledge is required to break up
"ano" from "yama"--"that mountain."
Finally,even if you're not familiar with Asian languages or ancient Latin,
you might have seen the same sort of thing in a much more modern guise,
in text messaging.
Some amount of domain knowledge is required to break this up into "I love you"
even though no particular spaces are given.
We will want to do the same thing for HTML to break it up into words
like "Wollstonecraft" and "wrote" that will appear on the screen
or this special left angle bracket slash maneuver that tells us that we're starting end tag,
this special word in the middle that tells us which tag it was,
and then this closing right angle bracket.
Once again, for this HTML fragment we want to break it up into this first word,
the start of the closing tag, another word, the end of the closing tag,
and then another word.
We're going to need to do this to write our web browser.
In order to interpret HTML and JavaScript, we're going to have to break sentences down
into their component words to figure out what's going on.
This process is called--dun, dun, dun, dun-- lexical analysis.
Lexical here has the same roots and "lexicon" like a dictionary.
This means "to break something down into words."
You'll be pleased to know that we're going to use regular expressions to solve this problem.
Here I've written another one of those decompositions.
We might have broken an HTML fragment down into these word-like objects,
but this time you're going to help me out by doing the problem in reverse.
So in this multiple multiple choice quiz, I'd like you to mark each one of these HTML fragments
that would decompose into this sequence of five elements.